hi Neil welcome to hi seeds and Hawaii
space exploration animal looking
simulation and I'm really excited to
give you guys a tour so come on let's go
this is the biology lab and this is our
astrobiologists Cyprian door so most of
the experiments we're doing here in this
lab are designed to figure out how we
can live on Mars from what is already 0
using biology so one of the alternatives
I'm working on is this insane bacteria
which are basically green microbes can
see them here which do photosynthesis
like plants and are very interesting in
this context because we could use
nutrients from the ground gases from the
atmosphere and water which we can follow
in different forms and Mars and once we
have grown them we can use them to
produce basically everything you need
fantastic alright so we remember to
bring the green bacteria sabrina is
doing amazing work here and so are some
of the other crew members it'll meet
soon all of our work is powered quite
literally by the Sun so let's look
outside so you can see the solar panel
system there it is that's where we get
almost all of our power so we have to go
outside to go cave explore collect rocks
we put on these suits we do our science
we do our exploring we come back we
recompress for five minutes and then we
can enter the habitat again around the
corner is maybe the second most
important feature to the have after the
power system i'm our toilet inverse
without water no flushing and then one
thing you didn't see through the window
is we have a solar stocks ID that is
used to distill the stuff that is
contained in these little buckets so
question if we really needed to could we
use what we collecting these toilets to
group food no way not even I wouldn't
really want to do it inside the house
I'm yeah pretty
the smiles look very nice no we haven't
had to go there but we could ok well
that's almost your entire tour of
simulated Mars last thing before we go
Neil
I just want to rerun it home today we
Martians heard your podcast about what
you would do with trash on Mars
my answer is what trash everything
continues to have a use the cycle it's a
loop and that's how we're gonna survive
in space we look forward to seeing you
as soon as we get back to earth or maybe
you'll join us here on Mars thanks guys